well you can just imagine the outrage of
this happened under a Republican
president a pair of liberal law
professors are calling for President
Biden to openly defy the Supreme Court
after he didn't get his way on
affirmative action and student debt
writing quote we urge President Biden to
restrain Maga justices immediately by
announcing that if and when they issue
rulings that are based on gravely
mistaken interpretations of the
Constitution the administration will be
will be guided by its own constitutional
interpretation
um so Dana I think this just exposes
that a lot of people on the left think
that the Supreme Court should be about a
super legislation to conservatives this
just continues what the left has been
trying to do to the court since bork
right so the left
say
my gosh we love the Supreme Court for
that decision but they hate them for all
the other decisions and most of the
decisions that the Supreme Court are 9-0
or 8-1 right and the most 7-2 the big
ones that are controversial yes but
Rasmussen just did a poll that said 63
percent of people uh pulled in that poll
liked approved of the course decision on
student loans and Chris
so determined that they didn't do
anything wrong and that also that
they're just going to change things so
they're not really bothered about it I
listened to a whole podcast this weekend
that Barry Weiss did with Larry Summers
who used to be the president of Harvard
and he's like this is no big deal this
is all overblown and Harvard really did
nothing wrong but they one of the things
that happened is that the media looks at
any sort of story that the left
especially younger people is upset about
and they run with it without ever
thinking it through that well like what
happened in our a block but I do think
that when you have the left saying that
basically they want Congress to take
over oversight of the Judiciary it means
that they really need to go back and
learn more about the separation of
powers yeah that's not how it's supposed
to be Jessica are these professors being
a little short-sighted because Biden
will not be the president forever
no another five and a half years but not
forever
obviously makes me think back to the
good old days of the filibuster right
and like Harry Reid with that
um but I would say in it maybe this is
going to open the floodgates and we're
going to hear a lot more about this so
far it's two professors saying that it's
a majority viewpoint on the left
definitely to expand the court but this
is obviously going a step further this
seems quite dangerous to me and they're
also asking the wrong president I mean
this is a guy who won't even entertain
the idea of expanding the court he looks
pretty Traditional Values and
perspectives about
you know recycling that there are nine
justices
um Etc so I don't think it's going to
work out
um I did want to say though on the
affirmative action front just something
that I thought was interesting because
you talking about what's going on at
Harvard did you guys see that Wesleyan
University banned legacy admissions
sorry I think it's yes it's amazing and
it's something also where there's
conservative and liberal agreement that
that should be uh gotten rid of so is
that a college Wesleyan or college not
University well I don't know I mean it's
a college it's a small Liberal Arts
Institute of Higher Learning right very
high yes so Drake is this a mistake
for this they're openly attacking and
undermining our institutions so I'm
getting tired of this extreme Maga
Democrat Party willing to overthrow the
country but it's true I mean you talk
and Jessica Joe credit brings up the
expanding Court uh goal it seems like
whenever things in the game don't go the
way Dems wanted to go they'll want
they'll prefer to change the game rather
than try to figure out how to win and
that happens when with a lot of things
including elections
I didn't hear that did you uh but it's
like I heard it and I'm all the way over
here yes it's interesting as a non-lefty
I'm okay without with how greedy the
left is but it's going too far I mean
you have government you got the Arts you
got media you got culture and now you're
mad because a few few things don't go
your way you know it's a little much
that Biden himself said we're
unconstitutional yeah exactly Jesse your
thoughts on scotus I did a deep dive on
these two I knew you would so you ready
this guy's not even a constitutional law
professor he's at San Francisco State
University a political science Professor
you ready who specializes in military
masculinity and sexuality in the armed
forces his major claim to fame is a book
he published called bring me men
military masculinity and the benign
facade of the American Empire sounds
like he knows a lot about the U.S
Constitution the other wacko from
Harvard yeah Harvard exactly this guy's
name is Mark tushnet now this guy is
such a wing nut he ascribes to something
called uh is it critical legal studies
it's like CRT for lawyers are you ready
he believes that the law currently is
trying to maintain the status quo and
codify its biases against marginalized
people and he said if he was a judge he
would make every decision based upon
what socialism would do so this is the
guy and this is the other guy who are
pushing this ridiculous thing to expand
the court and disobey the law so I'll
take a clown show
no that was the block before this uh CRT
started out as legal Theory but now it's
in your children's hospital birth to CRT
is that how we do it all right
it's coming up the New York Times is
warning people that going outside is
dangerous hi winner Brian Kilmeade I
want you to do me a favor I want you to
click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page the
only way that I know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on Fox
you can get it all here on YouTube so
subscribe right now